so does his float it so yes I have seen
it and um it's fine and I know that's
the things getting great reviews and a
lot of wringing endorsements and I'm not
gonna say anybody's wrong but for my
measure it was fine I expose a little
bit of context for that I've never read
the book I haven't seen the original
miniseries in its entirety it wasn't if
I'm sure if I'd seen it as a kid I
probably would have been scared by it
the parts and bits that I've seen I've
seen as an adult therefore it reads
pretty cheesy cuz I think if we're being
honest not a whole lot about that
miniseries says age well Tim Curry's
performance is kind of it so I came into
this movie pretty much without baggage
or a lot of expectations I mean I knew
the word was good but I don't have a
whole lot of investment or anything like
that involved in it so I came to this
pretty much cold and yeah it was fine I
I'll start with the positive stuff and
I'll get to the negative down line
because when I get into the negative is
it's gonna get into spoilers a little
bit not too heavily I'll try I'll try to
avoid them but as far as positive is the
big one the kids the kids are great like
all of them every single one and there's
a lot of kids there's like seven main
kids in this story and they're oh good
every single one of them and I mean I
can't I can't even remember some of the
characters names but I'm some of the
real standout Richie was Goodrich Richie
the one with the glasses always cracked
in the joke he could have been real
grating real fast but there's um there's
an honesty to the performance and I mean
there's an honesty the way the kids
behave in general because they behave in
a way that kids do behave but is rarely
allowed to be depicted depicted on film
like how casually they will drop the
f-bomb in the absence of grown-ups
around them stuff like that
the
really she was great she was really good
I really liked the Ben I thought he was
terrific too the guy who played Billy I
guess they're all good all the kids are
good so top notch on the kids that's my
main positive on the thing that's not to
say that everything else wasn't great
but that was the only element that I
came by going that really impressed me
because as I get into the rest of it and
think about it there were a lot of
little touches I liked and I thought
worked well but then there were almost
as many little things that kind of took
me out of the movie and this is where
I'm gonna get into some things that I
suppose constitute spoilers so if you
want the spoiler free version that's
pretty much it the kids are great I
didn't find it scary which i think is
kind of the big fall down I think unless
you find some of the imagery really
inherently unnerving or clowns just
scare you I don't think it's a
particularly scary movie it didn't do a
great job of ratcheting up the tension
at least for me maybe part of the
problem was I knew all these kids and
again I'm definitely gonna get into
spoilers at this point um maybe part of
the problem I knew is that all these
kids were going to survive because they
have to cuz they all appear as adults
and the second half of the story so
maybe that bit of knowledge was part of
the issue I don't know but there wasn't
a ton of tension in it for me so what I
said you know good and positive little
moments so like the soundtracks a good
thing I like a good example to talk
about because I liked the score the
score was very it was very 80s it was
very Amblin entertainment it was almost
et at SCAD times and that felt very
appropriate especially given the time
period that the film is set in but the
soundtrack like the songs that came in
the choice of song and the points that
they came out a few times I'm like
really like the the big one for me was
again again a scene that what that like
lost me and then won me back
the sinks
when like the hair is going after
Beverly and that that was pretty good
that was a pretty good scene and then
the the thing starts to spew the blood
and it's so much blood that it
completely lost me it made me think of
that scene from Evil Dead 2 whereas
shoots you know just a disembodied hand
behind the wall but then this hose of
blood comes out like it made me
immediately you think of that and the
scene lost me
but then when her father comes in and
doesn't see the blood normally what
would happen in a movie is that we would
then flash to you know the fiyo the
blood was not there at all but the fact
that it kept the blood there in shock
the whole time while he's going no
there's nothing here that wasn't that
was this slight variation from what you
used to seeing it was a good choice
because it really put you in Beverly's
shoes of being like what why can't you
see this so I mean again that's an
example of something that took me out of
the movie and then something else that
was a good touch that brought me back
but the reason I mentioned that is
because there's a song that plays during
basically a montage of the kids cleaning
up the bathroom and it's just weird it I
can't remember what the song was but I
just remember sitting there going really
okay I've kind of been I don't think
I've been dancing around the subject of
the clown but to talk about Pennywise
and Bill scars guards performance he
does it fine I mean he put he obviously
puts a lot of effort into it there's a
lot of physicality to it there's you
know some interesting tricks done with
some CGI modifications you know to his
look and then things about him and
that's all fine but there are other
things like he he has a strict there's
like three scenes in a row that's him
kind of stalking scaring different kids
out of this group out of the losers Club
and they are like back to back to back
and I remember thinking wait he's he's
just going down a checklist of all the
kids in town and so it was stuff like
that and this the person I went to the
movies with pointed this one out
and it kind of killed it for me because
this was pointed out really early on
bill skarsgård as penny whines he he
sounds like scooby Doo
I mean like really sounds like scooby
Doo basically scooby Doo without the
without that impediment where he sticks
are at the front of every word raggy
but he's so he's not doing that but that
cadence and tone and pitch
that's what Pennywise sounds like come
on Georgie come on down you're low down
here he sounded like scooby doo and yeah
that that made it hard for me to take
him seriously as being scary I think the
scene that was most effective for me in
terms of being unnerving was the stuff
with Georgie but I don't know how much
of that was how effective the scene was
or how much it just haven't hit my own
personal kind of hot-button I say that
because for me like trigger is too
strong a word I don't have quite that
stronger reaction to it but I have a
thing about children like eight years or
younger where they're terrified and in
real danger and and scared and can't do
anything about the situation that that
they're in and that just that makes me
inherently very deeply uncomfortable so
it hit that button for me but again I
don't know if if that speaks to how
effective the scene was in a vacuum or
how much it just happened to hit my own
button and at this point it probably
sounds like I'm really down on the film
I'm not I think it's it's pretty good
it's pretty decent but I also I'm never
gonna feel the need to watch this again
I'm not gonna feel a particular poll to
see the sequel because as I said the
best thing about this was the kids and
the sequels gonna have them as adults so
the kids aren't gonna be in it and yeah
that's kind of where I landed by the end
everything that's good about this is the
kid
and again the kids are awesome I do
really love the I love that they
basically beat this borderline cosmic
horror by beating the ever-loving crap
out of it I kind of love that but again
it's you know it's that those kinds of
things are offset by these other little
things that took me out of it like the
fact that there's a swimming scene
they're all in their underwear
really you're dead not not one of these
kids owns a bathing suit because it's
not like it was a spontaneous decision
they went there to the quarry to go
swimming and they know none of them
brought a bathing suit really and you
know it's stuff like that it's little
things like that across the whole movie
they just just kind of kind of killed it
for me I didn't have a bad time I don't
regret seeing it but nah didn't didn't
totally Joe for me so that's my feelings
on it my inclination is it's probably
gonna be an unpopular opinion but in any
case have you seen it what were your
thoughts on it whatever they are drop
something down in the comments and let's
talk about it don't forget to like
subscribe check me out on Twitter at
council of geeks give a listen to the
council of geeks podcast I am also one
half of the punch like a girl podcast
both of those are available on iTunes
and stitcher and until next time this
council is adjourned
[Applause]
[Applause]